THE COMMITTEE TO ORDER WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE -- NOT SEEING THE
PRESENCE OF A QUORUM --
SERGEANTS IF YOU COULD GO AHEAD
AND CALL THE OFFICES REMIND.
THE MEMBERS THAT WORK HAS BEGUN
IN THIS TIME TO SHOW UP.
WE WILL.
START IN SIGN IN ORDER AND USE
MISTER DALI HERE.
MISS DARCY PLEASE -- APPROACH
AND PRESENT YOUR BILL AB.
EIGHT FORTY REPRESENTS NUMBER --
SEVEN ON YOUR AGENDA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH ME -- IN MY
STAFF ON THE THIS BILL WE'RE
GONNA TAKE -- THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OF NUMBER ONE NUMBER
THREE NUMBER TWO WERE STILL
WORKING ON WITH THE ALCOHOL
BEVERAGE CONTROL BOARD -- TODAY
MEMBERS ANY AB EIGHT FORTY WHICH
DEALS WITH THE CAL NEVA RESORT
CASINO IN LAKE TAHOE AREAS OF
TEEN BEACH CALIFORNIA.
IN MY DISTRICT UP PART OF THE
BUILDING IS IN CALIFORNIA AND
PART OF THE BUILDING IS IN
NEVADA.
IT STRADDLES THE STATE LINE --
SO I HAVE WITH ME HERE KERRY --
BONDING HIM WITH SEEN IN HOTEL
HOLDINGS TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL IN ITS RE TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
RESPECT AS RELIABLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS KERRY BONDING TEN I'M A
PARTNER AT THE LAW FIRM
PILLSBURY WINTHROP SHAW PITTMAN.
I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF MY
CLIENT SEE AND HOLD A HOTEL
HOLDINGS.
HI AS YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD THE
CAL NEVA PROPERTY IS A VERY
UNIQUE PROPERTY IN THAT IT
SITUATED IN BOTH CALIFORNIA AND
NEVADA WE'RE NOT AWARE OF
ANOTHER LOCATION IN CALIFORNIA
THAT SHARES THAT SAME UNIQUENESS.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT UNIQUENESS
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL TO COME UP WITH
A LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION TO
ADDRESS THE FACT THAT THIS
PROPERTY HAS NEVER.
IN ITS HISTORY HELD AN ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE LICENSE -- SO WE'RE
WORKING -- TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
IN A WAY THAT SATISFACTORY TO
EVERYONE I'M HERE IF YOU HAVE
ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL.
OTHERWISE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU HAVE ANY OF THE OTHER --
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME.
DO WE HAVE ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NUMBER BRING IT BACK TO
THE MEMBERS -- FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS.
MR DAILY.
MISTER CHAIR JUST TO CLARIFY YOU
ARE RECOMMENDING -- AMENDMENTS
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER.
THREE THAT'S CORRECT GOOD JUST
CLARIFY THANKS.
TRANSITIONAL OUR COMMENTS
CONCERNS QUESTIONS SEEING NONE
AS SOON AS WE STATUS CORNER
STARLING WE WILL LOVE MOVE
FORWARD WITH YOUR BILL PROCEDURE --
PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS TIME.
FLOWS TO FLOOR YOU'VE DRAW THE
LUCKY NUMBER YEAH PLEASE --
APPROACHING PRESENT.
ITEM NUMBER -- FOURTEEN SHE'S.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB FOURTEEN
NINETY NINE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
WE DO HAVE A COUPLE WITNESSES
THAT MAY COME UP FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS SO WHEN THEY GET HERE
THEY MAY APPROACH AS WELL.
SO.
THEY RICHARD MEMBERS WANT TO
START BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT AND THANK YOU CAN YOU
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR EFFORTS
IN HELPING CRAP THIS BILL I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB.
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE WHICH WOULD
CREATE A GRANT PROGRAM IN THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES TO
MAKE EMERGENCY INTER OPERABILITY
SYSTEM FUNDING AVAILABLE. TO K.
THROUGH TWELVE PUBLIC SCHOOLS
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND STATE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITIES.
AS WE ALL KNOW THE ACTIVE
SHOOTER INCIDENTS ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES ARE INCREASING AT AN
ALARMING RATE.
IN FACT IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER INCIDENT OCCURRING ONCE
EVERY FIVE DAYS ON A K. THROUGH
TWELVE CAMPUS.
AND ONCE EVERY EIGHT DAYS ON THE
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY CAMPUS.
IN OPERABILITY TECHNOLOGY ALLOW
OUR SCHOOL STAFF.
TO PRESS A SOFT PANIC BUTTON ON
THEIR CELL PHONE.
AND GIVE ALL LOCAL FIRST
RESPONDERS THE MEDIA VIDEO AND
AUDIO ACCESS TO THE CRISIS AT
HAND.
THIS ACCESS WOULD ENHANCE FIRST
RESPONSIBILITY QUICKLY CONTROL
THE MATTER IN AN EFFORT TO
MINIMIZE CASUALTIES.
AB NINETY I'M SORRY A. B.
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO SAVE
STUDENTS LIVES IN CALIFORNIA.
NOT ONLY FROM ACTIVE SHOOTERS
BUT FROM ANY POTENTIAL HARM TO
MAKE COME THEIR WAY WHILE AT
SCHOOL COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JUST FORTY S.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY.
YES MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JOHN LEVEL I'M
REPRESENTING THE COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION.
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY POLICE
CHIEFS IN CALIFORNIA PROTECT
ABOUT THREE MILLION PEOPLE
STUDENTS AND THE STAFF OF THE
CAMPUS IS THEIR SWORN TO PROTECT.
AND WHAT THEY'VE DISCOVERED OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS HAS BEEN
AN ALARMING INCREASE.
IN ACTIVE SHOOTER INCIDENTS AS
MR FLORA -- INDICATED THE THERE
IS A THESE ARE NATIONWIDE STATS.
THERE IS A SHOOTING ON A COLLEGE
CAMPUS ONCE EVERY EIGHT DAYS
THAT'S A VERY DISTURBING
NORMALIZATION.
SO WE'VE STRUGGLED WITH THIS
ISSUE FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS --
AND ONLY THIS YEAR HAVE WE COME --
INVOLVED WITH THE INTER
OPERABILITY CONCEPT WHICH IS
EMBODIED IN THIS BILL AND TRULY
AN EXCITING.
PROBLEM SOLVING CONCEPT -- WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY YES.
YES I'M RYAN BROOKS AND AS FOR
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS AS A POLICE
OFFICER CALIFORNIA -- RETIRES
THIS IS THE CHIEF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND THEN RAN THE THE CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL TALK TO CENTER IN
SERVICES GROUP COVERING THE
COUNTIES FROM SAN LUIS OBISPO
NORTH OF THE OREGON BORDER. ONE
OF THE PROBLEMS WE TRY TO SOLVE
IS HOW WE BETTER INTEROP --
SINCE NINE ELEVEN SINCE THE NINE
ELEVEN COMMISSION REPORT --
CALLED OUT THE PROBLEM OF INTER
OPERABILITY -- I THINK THAT MOST
PEOPLE IN AMERICA BELIEVE THAT
WE SOLVE THAT FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
FOR POLICE FOR FIRE. FOR
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AGENCY SAID
FOR EMS.
BUT THE REALITY IS WE HAVEN'T --
THE REALITY IS WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF A FEW POCKETS.
LIKE NEW JERSEY AND NEW YORK IN
CENTRAL FLORIDA WHERE THEY'VE
EMPLOYED SOME TECHNOLOGIES TO
BRIDGE THAT INTER OPERABILITY.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT IN
ITS MOST EVIDENT WE HAVE A A
SHOOTING AT A SCHOOL.
IN A WERE OUR MOST VULNERABLE
AND MOST PRECIOUS.
THE THINGS THAT ARE THE MOST
PRECIOUS THINGS TO US -- ARE
WHERE THEY SHOULD FEEL SAFE --
SO.
WHICH RICK WHICH REALLY REQUIRED
IN THE REALITY IS WHEN YOU CAN
REDUCE -- TIME TO RESOLUTION.
WHEN YOU CAN REDUCE THAT TIME TO
RESPOND?
IN WOULD YOU COULDN'T IMPROVE --
THE THE IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY
OF THE RESPONDING AGENCIES
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU HAVE MUTUAL
AID AGENCIES RESPONDING YEAH.
YOU'RE GOING TO SAVE LIVES.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHETHER THAT'S
A SCHOOL SHOOTING.
WE'RE SHOOTING A BALL OR A FIRE.
OR FLOOD OR EARTHQUAKE BUT IT IS
GOING TO DRAMATICALLY IMPROVE --
YOU KNOW HOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
FIRE EMS RESPONSE THOSE
INCIDENTS.
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS AVAILABLE
TODAY.
THAT COULD BE USED IN THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES ALLOW NOT ONLY FOR
A PANIC ALARM SOFT PANIC ALARMS
FOR EVERY TEACHER.
AND HARD PANIC ALARMS IN EVERY
SCHOOL BUT WITH THOSE WHO ARE
WHEN THOSE ARE TRIGGERED THAT
ALLOWS.
THE SCHOOL RADIO SYSTEM IN THE
LAWN FIRST RADIO SYSTEM IN THE
FIRE IN THE M. S. RADIO SYSTEMS
TO SHARE.
ALLOWS THEM TO SHARE THEIR THEIR
SECURITY VIDEO.
IN ALLOWS THEM TO DO THAT
SECURELY.
IN A NETWORK WE'RE NOBODY OWNS
THE MIDDLE WHERE NOBODY HAS TO
SEE THEIR SOVEREIGNTY OF THEIR
DATA.
WHAT WERE IT IS SHARED FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THAT IS AND WHETHER
IT'S A PLANNED EVENT LIKE
SUPERBOWL -- OR WHETHER IT'S AN
UNPLANNED EVENT LIKE A SCHOOL
SHOOTER MALL SHOOTER IN HERE'S
THE BEAUTY OF THIS.
IF WE CONNECT SCHOOL EIGHT WITH
POLICE DEPARTMENT NAY.
AT SCHOOL BE WHAT POLICE
DEPARTMENT BE.
WITHOUT CONNECTED PLEASED BERMAN
A. B. AS WELL.
WITHOUT KEL CONNECTED SCHOOL A
AND B. AS WELL BECAUSE THEY'RE
ALL ON THE NETWORK AND WE'VE
DONE THAT AND THOUSANDS OF
INSTANCES.
USING TECHNOLOGY LIKE THIS IN
FLORIDA -- AS RESPONSIBLE
PARKING SHOOTING -- AND WE'VE
DONE THAT WITH A RESOUNDING --
SUPPORT OF THE ACLU.
BUT NO CONCERNS OF PRIVACY OR
CIVIL LIBERTIES FOR CIVIL RIGHTS --
ISSUES BECAUSE I'M NOT GIVING UP
MY DATA YOU CAN'T TAKE MY DATA.
IT'S AN ASKING EXCEPT I HAVE AN
INCIDENT.
I INVITE THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
IN A FIGHT THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
IN WERE NOW SHARING OR VIDEO
WE'RE SHOWING AT A TABLE OWN
HOME STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
ROUTE REALLY THE CRADLE OF
TECHNOLOGY I MEAN I WAS RAISED
IN SAN JOSE WAY BEFORE SILICON
VALLEY.
BUT THIS KIND OF TECHNOLOGY I TO
BE IN USE HERE IT'S THE ONLY WAY
THAT WE'RE GOING TO ENSURE.
THE SAFETY OF OUR KIDS IN
SCHOOLS.
BUT ALSO TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES SO I URGE
SUPPORT ON THIS.
THANK YOU BRIDGE THE DIGITAL
TESTIMONY -- MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MATTHEW CYBERLINK WE
HAVE THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
PROTECTIVE LEAGUE AND I
CALIFORNIA NARCOTICS OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION -- JUST IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME JUST WANTED --
TO TO BOLSTER THE WORDS OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY -- IT'S IT'S UTILITY
TO PEACE OFFICERS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS WHO ARE DEPLOYED TO
THESE -- OFTEN CHAOTIC EVENTS.
TO LOT AND COMMUNICATE WITH EACH
OTHER AND EFFECTIVELY RESOLVE
THEM QUICKLY TO TO SAVE LIVES.
WE ARE DR -- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE DO WE HAVE ANY
TESTIMONY HERE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS MISTER COOPER AND
THEN WE'LL HAVE WHICH MATHIS
THANK YOU MISTER SHARON THINKING
THE NUMBER -- FROM RIPON FOR
BRING THIS -- FOREIGN CHIEF FOR
TESTIFYING SO IMPORTANT -- INTER
OPERABILITY AND ONE WONDERFUL SO
REALIZE JUST FIRST A SINGLE
PORTAL RADIO IS FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
THINK ABOUT THAT TIME THE
CHAUCER OUT THERE SO THIS GRANT
WILL GO A LONG WAY.
IN HELPING THE AGENCIES AND
MISTER FLOORS OF FIREFIGHTER
FORMER OCCUR FIREFIGHTER THANK
YOU REALIZE MORE THAN ANYBODY
THAT BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE TALK
ABOUT THESE THINGS.
ACTUALLY MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE.
AND ALSO THE COST OF A A HARD
MOUNTED -- REDUCES IN THE
VEHICLE I THINK BY ABOUT FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS SO.
NO TIMES THATWE HAVE LA.
LAPD THEY GOT SEVEN THOUSAND
OFFICERS AND I WAS OFFICE HAVE
PORTABLE RADIOS SO AND YOU THEY
DO GET UPGRADED.
TECHNOLOGY GETS OLD SO THANK YOU
FOR BEING THIS BILL FORWARD
[inaudible]
THEY DISCOVER.
OKAY THIS MATHIS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AMISH FARMER THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- YOU
HAVE BEEN TALKING WITH MY COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS AND
TULARE COUNTY TO HIRE.
AND YOU SHARED WITH ME THEY'RE
ACTUALLY WORKING ON A PROGRAM
JUST LIKE THIS -- TO BE ABLE TO
DO HE SILENT ALARMS TO BE ABLE
TO TELL -- WHICH WE DOORS OPEN
INSIDE A BUILDING SHOW OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS ARE COMING IN -- CAN
KNOW THESE THINGS IN WHERE THE
THE FACULTY CAN ACTUALLY CLICK
ON THEIR PHONE ON THE MAP ONCE
THEY OPTED TO SHARE THE DATA.
THEY CAN LITERALLY.
CLICK ON THEIR PHONE.
IN SHOW HE WE KNOW THE SHOOTERS
HERE.
AND TALK WITH THE DISPATCHER AND
TEAM AND EVERYTHING ELSE THAT
WAY THEY CAN ALL WORK IN CONCERT
TOGETHER. TO GET OUR CHILDREN TO
SAFETY CHAU SEEN THIS COME FOR I
I THINK IS A GREAT BILL -- IF
I'M NOT ALREADY A CO AUTHOR
PLEASE ADD ME ON TO IT.
HELLO WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE IS SOMETHING THAT'S
EXTREMELY NEEDED -- MY TEARS
TIMES WHEN OVERSEAS WE HAD THE
ABILITY TO DO THIS -- IT WITHIN
THE COMBAT THEATER TO ADJUST FOR
ENEMY FIRE IN FRIENDLIES AND
EVERYTHING ELSE SO IT'S ABOUT
TIME WE BRING THAT TECHNOLOGY
HERE TO PROTECT OUR KIDS THANK
YOU.
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS -- COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS.
SEEING THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MISTER FLORES RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR EITHER THANK YOU.
CHOOSE WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM WE
WILL -- MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
LEGISLATION THANK YOU SIR.
OKAY AT THIS TIME I SEE MISTER
KANSEN CHU.
IN THE AUDIENCE PLEASE
CHARACTERS THAT YOUR BILLS AND
IN THE MEANTIME I'D LIKE TO PAGE
MISTER ROB BONTA ROOM -- FORTY
TWO OH TWO ASSEMBLY GOVERNMENT
ORDERS AGE COMMITTEE PLEASE
REPORT TO ROOM
.
FORTY TWO OH TWO WELL MISTER
CHIU APPROACHES WILL GO AHEAD
AND PAGE MISTER MARC BERMAN
PLEASE REPORT TO ROOM FORTY TWO
OH TWO ASSEMBLY GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE.
MR TO BEGIN -- ENSURE.
DISCUSSION JOINT SECRETARY MUCH
TIME -- ALSO WORKING POEM THE CO
AUTHOR OF A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE.
SO I'M HOPING THAT HE IS ON HIS
WAY DOWN HERE.
WELL ALL GET STARTED I HAVE TWO
MORE OF MORE PICKED THE
WITNESSES WITH ME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHARE AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB.
SEVEN WHICH WAS SET TO
CALIFORNIA DAYLIGHT SAVING TIME
ALL YEAR ROUND.
PENDING FEDERAL APPROVAL.
IF PASSED THE BILL WILL GO INTO
EFFECT.
THE MARCH FOLLOWING THE FEDERAL
AUTHORIZATION.
IN NOVEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA VOTERS EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT TO ELIMINATE THE BI
ANNUAL TIME SWITCH.
WITH WAS SO MORE THAN 60%
APPROVAL OF THE BALLOT MEASURE
THE AT EIGHT OF THOSE SO. SEVEN
RIGHT -- AND THE LEGISLATURE TO
TO GIVE THE AUTHORITY TO THE
LEGISLATURE. TO CONSIDER THIS A
ISSUE -- BUT STUDY HAVE LONG
SHOWN THAT NEGATIVE THE FACT OF
THE BY AND YOU'LL TIME SWITCH
INCLUDING INCREASING TRAFFIC AND
WORKPLACE ACCIDENT.
HARD TO HAVE A STROKE APOLOGIZE
FOR INTERRUPTING BUT WE'VE.
ESTABLISHED A QUEER WE HAVE A
NUMBER FOR A QUORUM SO WE'RE
GONNA GO HEAD TO STATUS.
AND WHILE WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND WE'LL GET BACK
YOUR PRESENTATION I APOLOGIES
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY.
HERE BIGELOW.
AND YOUR COURAGE.
BERMAN [inaudible]
CONTACT [inaudible]
BRO.
LEAVE.
YOUR COOPER.
DALY HERE.
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA GIPSON [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY HERE.
LOW [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MELENDEZ.
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS.
WANT TO RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
PLEASE PROCEEDS ARE GREAT THANK
YOU THERE YOU HAVE A CALL QUORUM
I GOT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE HERE.
SO WE'RE WE'RE ON THE AND THE AB
SEVEN WHICH IS THE FOLLOW UP.
BY THE PROPOSITION SEVEN THAT
WAS PASSED BY DOUBLE TURN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WAS MORE THAN 60%.
OF THE APPROVAL.
AND WILL OVER IS TRYING TO
ADDRESS TO STUDY ON MEDICAL
STUDY THE SHOWN THAT NEGATIVE A
FACT OFF TO BI ANNUAL TIME
SWITCHING.
UNCLEAN INCREASE TRAFFIC AND
WORKPLACE ACCIDENT A HEART
ATTACK AND STROKE ON THE DAY
FOLLOWING THIS SPRING.
FOR PASSING PROPOSITION SEVEN
HAS SANDER RIPPLE FAR EFFECT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO CONSIDER
THE SCIENCE BEHIND THE PRACTICE.
AND IS HOME FOR EFFECT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN ALONE THIRTY NIGHT.
THIRTY NINE STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HAVE INTRODUCED A
SIMILAR LEGISLATIN. TO OF IT
TAKE IT THE EXPRESSION IN
INTERESTS AND DISPATCHED TO
SWITCH.
AND ELIMINATING THE BI ANNUAL
TIMES WHICH THIRTY NINE STATE.
OF FLORIDA ALREADY PASSED A
SIMILAR LEGISLATION LAST YEAR --
INCLUDING A DAY WHAT DAY WAS
SWITCHED TO PROMOTE THE BILL.
PERMANENT DAYLIGHT SAVING TIME
WE HAVE A MOTION.
THE SHIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
AND THIS YEAR THERE'S THREE
DIFFERENT PIECES OFF OF FEDERAL
LEGISLATION HAS BEEN INTRODUCED.
TO PLACE TO THE COUNTRY ON
BAILEY'S DAYLIGHT SAVING TIME
YOUR WRONG OR GIVE STATE
DISCOURAGE DISCRETION TO CHOOSE
STANDARD TIME ORDERED A DAYLIGHT
SAVING TIME.
THIS BILL WHAT'S ALSO BY -- AND
SOUND OF HER MARCO RUBIO AND MY
CONGRESSMAN ROLE CON THE THIS
WAS ONE OF THE CO SPONSOR OF A
BILL.
SO DOES OSAMA YOU WONDER HOW
WILL THIS CHANGE CORRESPOND WITH
OUR NEIGHBORS.
AND TO DO DO YOU ANSWER IS THAT
DIRECTLY TO OUR NORSE OREGON
STATE.
A POSSIBLE TO PLACE TO STAY ON
PERMANENT DAYLIGHT SAVING TIME.
AND WASHINGTON STATE.
SENATE AND HOUSE HAVE PASSED OF
COURSE FUNDING LEGISLATION
ALTHOUGH IF THEIR FIRST HOUSE.
THE LAST YEAR DOES BODY PASSED A
BILL TO ALLOW VOTER TO
RECONSIDR THE PRACTICE OF
SWITCHING OUR CLOCK.
AND THE VOTER HAS SPOKEN AND IS
TIME FOR US TO DELIVER.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO OF US OR AND OF
A FRIEND.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE TO ADD
A FEW COMMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WELCOME MISTRAL NOT ALTER
OUR MIND YOU HAVE A SUPPORT
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION A MOTION
AND A SECOND PLEASE PROCEED OUR
CONFEREES.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO BE JOINT
AUTHOR OF AB SEVEN I BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS WOULD BE A GREAT
THING TO CARE FOR CALIFORNIANS
IN ADDITION TO THE THINGS THAT
MY JOINT AUTHORED.
RAISED -- THERE ARE COMPELLING
REASONS WHY WE NEED TO GO TO
FULL TIME DAYLIGHT SAVINGS TIME.
GOING TO FULL TIME DAYLIGHT
SAVINGS TIME WOULD NOT ONLY SAVE
THOUSANDS OF MEGAWATTS OF
ELECTRICITY YEAR WOULD ALSO
LOWER INDUSTRIAL ACCIDENTS IT
WOULD LOWER THE RATE OF
RESIDENTIAL BURGLARIES THE
RESEARCH SAYS IT WOULD ALSO
LOWER.
PEDESTRIAN ACCIDENTS IN
VEHICULAR ACCIDENTS THE
SCIENTIFIC DATA IS VERY
COMPELLING THAT THIS WOULD BE
GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT.
OKAY THANK YOU I SEE THAT YOU
HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
HERE TODAY IF THEY HAVE SOME
BRIEF COMMENTS THEY'D LIKE TO
SHARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
YES WE HAVE A THE DOCTOR
CARDIOLOGISTS THE DOCTOR EVELYN
LEAD.
AND MARK.
TEN FOR A MARCH ON THE SENATE
FLOOR OPEN SPACE AUTHORITY.
GOODAFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN MY NAME IS DOCTOR EVELYN
LEE AND I'VE BEEN A
CARDIOLOGISTS WITH THIRTY SIX
YEARS.
I WORK IN FREMONT IN THE BAY
AREA I SUPPORT AB SEVEN AND
KEEPING THE STATE ON DAYLIGHT
SAVING TIME YEAR ROUND.
DST WAS INVENTED IN NINETEEN
SIXTEEN DURING THE WARTIMETO
CONSERVE ENERGY BUT NOW WE FIND
THAT NOT ONLY WILL NOTS SAVING
THE ENERGY BUT WE ARE CREATING
MORE HARM THAN GOOD.
BECAUSE THE EXTRA HOURS OF LOSS
OF SLEEP WE SEE SEVEN POINT 6%
MORE FATAL CAR CRASHES.
A STUDY BEEN DONE BY JOHN
HOPKINS AND STANFORD UNIVERSITY
ANALYZE TWENTY ONE YEARS WORTH
OF FATAL CAR CRASHES THEY FIND
83% EIGHTY THREE MORE DEATHS.
EIGHTY THREE DEATH COMPARED TO
SEVENTY EIGHT DEATH ON THE
AVERAGE MONDAYS IN A CAR CRASH.
THERE'S A FIVE POINT 7% JUMP IN
WORKPLACE INJURIES AND NEARLY
68% MORE WORK THEY LOST TO
INJURIES.
MICHIGAN HOSPITAL HAS DONE A
STUDY SHOWING 34% INCREASE IN
HEART ATTACK 25% JUMP IN NUMBERS
A HEART ATTACK TO SUCK THE
MONDAY AFTER WE CHANGE THE CLOCK.
COMPARED TO OTHER MONDAYS AND
THE OPPOSITE EFFECT IS ALSO TRUE
STUDY SHOWS THAT 21% DROP IN
HEART ATTACK ON A DAY AFTER WE
TURN TO THE STANDARD TIME.
WHEN WE GAIN AN EXTRA HOUR?
STUDY IT WAS PRESENTED IN
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF NEUROLOGY
INTO A ONE SIX CONFERENCE ALSO
LINKED TO AN INCREASE IN RISK
SOFT ISCHEMIC STROKE RELATED TO
THE CHANGE OF DAYLIGHT SAVING
TIME.
SO.
I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE. FOR A.
B..
SEVEN THANK YOU UP MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MARK
LAND ROUGH WITH THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY OPEN SPACE AT THE READY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN THE OPEN SPACE AUTHORITIES
A LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCY WHOSE
MISSION IS TO PRESERVE NATURAL
RESOURCES -- SUPPORT AGRICULTURE
AND CONNECT PEOPLE TO NATURE.
PARKS AND OPEN SPACE PRESERVES
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY OPERATED
BY OUR AGENCY AND OUR PARTNER
SEE OVER FIVE MILLION VISITORS.
PER YEAR AND THERE'S CLEAR
DEMAND FOR MUCH MORE OPPORTUNITY.
FOR VISITATION AT OPEN SPACE
PRESERVES A PERMANENT DAYLIGHT
SAVINGS TIME WOULD PROVIDE MORE
DAYLIGHT HOURS OUTSIDE OF WORK
HOURS. FOR RESIDENTS TO EXPLORE
THEIR TREASURED PARKS AND OPEN
SPACES WHAT'S MORE THE OPEN
SPACE AUTHORITY INVEST
SIGNIFICANTLY IN EFFORTS TO
MITIGATE CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND SEES THE POTENTIAL FOR
ENERGY RELATED BENEFITS FROM
EIGHTY SEVEN ALIGNING WITH OUR
WORK TO REDUCE CLIMATE --
INDUCED IMPACTS WE APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL AND IN
SO MANY OTHER COMMUNITY RELATED
ISSUES HE OPEN SPACE AUTHORITY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
DIGITAL TEST WERE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NOT ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS.
SEEING THAT WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND THIS IS DUE PASSED
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE --
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GREAT. FIVE THREE I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO.
ROW NOW COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
COOPER.
COOPER AYE DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
AND WE'RE GARCIA GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
HELLO.
LOW I MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE.
QUIRK SILVA AYE QUIRK SILVA AYE
ROBERT RIVAS.
BLANCA RUBIO I WANT TO RUBIO AYE
SALAS.
THAT IS OUT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION --
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM. TWO ON
THE AGENDA AB TWO NINETY ONE
ALSO -- BY MR KANSEN CHU.
MEMBERS WHILE WE'RE MAKING THE
TRANSITION -- LITTLE
HOUSEKEEPING ITEM THREE AB FOR
SEVENTY FIVE ASIAN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA.
BY UNANIMOUS CONSENT ITEM
SIXTEEN AB FIFTEEN FORTY EIGHT
HAS BEEN ADDED TO THE SECOND --
ONE WE HAVE TEN BILLS ON THE
PROPOSED CONSECUTIVE -- ITEMS
461-014-1617 EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE IF NO ONE
OBJECTS THE PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR MAY HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
OCEAN THE SECOND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GREAT.
HI GREAT I AM BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CONTACT.
RO RO AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
UBER IDEALLY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
SEE I GET SENT -- GIVES IT.
GIVES AN AYE JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LOW.
LOW HI MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE AYE QUIRK SILVA.
SOME I ROBERT RIVAS.
BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO AYE
SALAS.
SALAS AYE.
OKAY CONSENT CALENDAR ADOPTED
WHICH CHIU PLEASE -- PROCEED
WITH YOUR NEXT BILL SIR.
THANK YOU CHAIRED REMEMBERS AB
TWO NINETY ONE WILL ESTABLISH A
LOCAL EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS AND
HAZARD MITIGATION FUND. TO
ENSURE ALL CITIES AND COUNTIES
ARE PREPARE FOR ANY DISASTER
THAT MIGHT COME THEIR WAY.
THE PHONE WAS A POOR PLANNING
MITIGATION EFFORT.
AS AND STAFFING SO LOW WE HAD
ALL OCEAN OF THE SECOND CAN HELP
RESOURCES TO MEET EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS NEED.
MY BILL IS FABULOUS FOR LOCAL
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS AND
HAZARDOUS MITIGATION FUND
COMMITTEE.
I WAS OVERSIGHT BY THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES WIZARD
REPRESENTATIVE FROM LOCAL CITIES
COUNTIES AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
TO SET.
A GUIDANCE FOR HOW JURISDICTION
WERE USED TO FUND.
THEY ARE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY COMPONENTS OF
BUILDING TO THIS BILL TO REQUIRE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT RECEIVING FUN
TO IDENTIFY HOLLOW DAY ARE BEING
USED.
AND A POSITIVE BENEFIT RELATED
TO LOCAL EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
EFFORTS.
IF IF IF FUNDS ARE NOT BEING
USED AS INTENDED MY BILL ALLOW --
FOR YES AND THE COMMUNITY TO
WITHHOLD FUNDING FOR FUTURE
PROJECTS OR MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR IMPROVEMENT.
I HAVE LONG TALKING POINTS BUT
IT SEEMS WILL REALLY HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND I'LL WHICH
BUT I MAKE IT SHORT.
AND INTRODUCE OF OF THE VICE
MAYOR FROM SAN JOSE CHOPPY JONES
AND JOINING US IN AND TOUGH
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT AND ALSO
COUNCIL MEMBER RAUL PARALYSIS
JOE WAS ME ALSO TODAY WHEN THIS
IS.
A SUPPORTER A RAID -- THE RIDE
THEN TO DIRECTOR OF OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT. FOR THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE AND CHARLES.
HARVEY THE LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES.
THANK YOU WELCOME TO ALL OF YOU
PLEASE -- PROCEED WITH YOUR
BRIEF COMMENTS ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU HONORABLE COMMITTEE
CHAIR MEMBERS THE ASSEMBLY THE
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE PANELISTS
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
ATTENDING TODAY.
I THINK IT IS A MOMENT CARE
KANSEN CHU FOR OFFERING THIS
LEGISLATION.
MY NAME IS RAYMOND RIORDAN OF
THE DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT FOR THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE SINCE MARCH OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BEFORE
STARTING AT SAN JOSE I SERVED
THIRTY TWO YEARS AS EMERGENCY
MANAGER. FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT AT
THE STATE LEVEL FEDERAL LEVEL
AND SPECIAL DISTRICT LEVEL.
I'M ALSO CURRENTLY THE STATE
PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY SERVICES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTS OVER SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY MEMBERS.
WHO ARE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT OF%
CITIES COUNTIES PUBLIC HEALTH
MEDICAL HEALTH AND PRIVATE
SECTOR AGENCIES?
WATER CEASES MISSIONS IS TO WORK
WITH CALORIE ASKED TO SUPPORT
PLANNING TRAINING AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT FIELD.
I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB.
TWO NINETY ONE BOB MIKE SHORT
BRIEF NOTES WILL BE FOCUSED ON
THE DISASTERS AND HOW THEY ARE
LOCAL.
LOOK DISASTERS ARE LOCALS TOP
THAT WAY BY THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS IT'S OUR
LOCAL POLICE FIRE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT FOR THE FIRST TO
RESPOND TO SET.
UP ALERTS AND WARNINGS AND TO
TAKE ACTION TO MAKE THE FIRST
DECISIONS.
IN THE ACTIONS IN RESPONSE IT IS
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND MUST
MANAGE RECOVERY FOLLOWING THE
DISASTER.
WE ARE THE FIRST TO WHOM THE
PUBLIC LOOKS TO FOR INFORMATION
DECISIONS AND COMMUNITY FOCUS
LEADERSHIP.
WE ARE THE ONES WHO PROVIDE
COMPASSION IN ACTION FOR THOSE
AFFECTED BY THE EMERGENCIES.
WITH THE RECENT INCREASE OF
DISASTERS THAT WE SEE IN THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS WE DO URGE
AND HAVE THE NEED FOR ONE A
LOCAL ECONOMIES AFFECTED.
IT BY A DISASTER IT RIPPLES
THROUGH THE STATE ECONOMY SO WE
DO SEE A NEED TO HAVE THIS THIS
STATE FUNNY TO SUPPORT THE LOCAL
NEEDS.
WITH THAT'LL BE VERY BRIEF AND
GO MY CONCLUDING COMMENTS.
WHICH ARE -- AS NOTED BY THE
CALORIE ESTATE HAZARD MITIGATION
PLAN THE THREE PRIORITY HAZARDS
EARTHQUAKE FIRE AND FLOOD.
WHICH WILL IMPACT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THOSE ECONOMIES
WE NEED THE STATE FUNDING THE
LEVERAGED LOCAL DOLLARS TO FILL
CRITICAL GAPS IN PREPAREDNESS
AND RESPONSE.
AND THAT'S OUR OWN ONE OF THE
COMMENTS THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
WHAT IS SAID IS THAT FOR EVERY
DOLLAR INVESTED.
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
MITIGATION WE SAVE SIX DOLLARS
AND RECOVERY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR DO YOU
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL -- BRIEF
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT.
YEAH LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
UP SORRY JOHN SORRY WE HAVE TO
LEAVE CALIFORNIA CITIES TO CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- WE
VERY MUCH SUPPORT -- THE EFFORT
TO BRING ADDITIONAL DOLLARS --
FOR CITIES TO ASSIST THEIR HAS
MITIGATION PLANNING -- WE'VE
BEEN AN ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE SPONSOR AND IN
EXPLORING HOW WE CAN ENHANCE THE
MEASURE IN A WAY THAT MORE OR
LESS PRIORITIZE THE PURPLE
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
A TO THOSE CITIES THAT BEAR THE
HIGHEST RISK OF FACING A
WILDFIRE EARTHQUAKE OR FLOOD --
WITH THAT SAID WE LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AND SPONSOR AND
WE APPRECIATE OTHERS LEADERS
WHEN THIS ISSUE ENERGY SUPPORT
THANK YOU SIR.
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS -- YES THANK
YOU I CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON THAT VICE MAYOR
CHEVY JONES FROM THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE.
AND I WANT TO COME IN SOME WOMEN
CHIU FOR ON THIS BILL -- AS A
SOMEONE WHO'S GONE THROUGH THE
LOMA PRIETA EARTHQUAKE AS WELL
AS THE OAKLAND FIRES IN.
NINETY ONE AS WELL AS SOME OF
THE MOST RECENT FLOODING THAT
WE'VE HAD IN SAN JOSE.
IS VERY CLEAR TO US THAT IT HAS
BEEN MENTIONED THAT.
A DOLLAR SPENT NOW. FOR
PREVENTION IT'S GONNA SAVE SIX
DOLLARS IN THE FUTURE WE KNOW
THAT IF WE INVEST NOW AND TAKE
THE MEASURES THAT WILL PREPARE
US. FOR THESE.
DISASTERS THAT ARE GOING TO
HAPPEN IS NOT A MAYBE IT'S A WIN.
THAT WILL BE BETTER PREPARED IT
WILL BE ABLE TO NOT ONLY SAY
PROPERTY.
BUT ALSO SAVE LIVES SO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS THIS BILL
WE HOPE THAT YOU DO.
TO THANK YOU ALL.
THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS ROLE
PROBABLY CITY COUNCIL
REPRESENTATIVE FOR DOWNTOWN SAN
JOSE -- MY COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND
DISTRICT WHERE GROUND. ZERO TWO
YEARS AGO DURING THE FLOODS IN
SAN JOSE.
I ALSO SERVED EIGHT YEARS IN THE
SAN JOSE POLICE DEPARTMENT STILL
CURRENTLY SERVES A RESERVE AND
WORK PART OF THAT IS AN
EMERGENCY MEDICAL TECHNICIAN --
URGENCY PREPAREDNESS -- IS
SOMETHING THAT I HAVE WORKED
WITH IN MY ENTIRE CAREER BUT I
CAN TELL YOU I WANT TO THINK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU IS WELL --
FOR BRINGING FORWARD THIS BILL
WE ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT I WAS
PREPARED PERSONALLY FOR THIRTY
SECONDS OF COMMENTS SO I WILL
KEEP IT AT THAT SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THE ADDITIONAL.
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M AT THE
HAWKINS I'M REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION -- FIRST THANK YOU
FOR TAKING UP -- AB TWO NINETY
ONE I THINK IT'S A CRITICAL BILL --
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION AS IT BRINGS MUCH
NEEDED FUNDING TO THE LOCALS IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO ACTUALLY BUILD
THEIR EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS SUSTAIN INVESTMENTS --
AND MITIGATION ACTIVITIES AND
BUILD BE EXISTING PROGRAMS IN
THE STATE SUPPORTING LOCAL SUCH
THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE
NECESSARILY ONLY RELY ON FEDERAL
FUNDING -- WE URGE SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DIGITAL TEST MIGHT SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE DO WE HAVE ANY
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
A VERY BRIEFLY MICHAEL RIGHT
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AS YOUR ANALYSIS
INDICATES WE DID COMMUNICATE OUR
OPPOSITION -- ANALYSTS AMENDED
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL IN ITS PRESENT
FORM.
HOWEVER WE HAVE BEEN ENGAGED IN
SOME MEANINGFUL BENEFICIAL
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE SPONSOR AND
THE AUTHORS OFFICE.
AND WE'RE CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC
THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO WORK OUT
THOSE CREMATED ASHES THANK YOU.
THE FOR THOSE COMMENTS EMERGING
AS THE AUTHORS WILL BE TAKING
THE BE -- A MEMBER TO SUGGEST IN
THE COMMITTEE NOW SAYS THAT
CRACK MISCHIEF.
EXCELLENT ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY SEEING NONE WILL BRING
ABOUT TO THE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE MOST OF THE
SECOND MEASURE CHU IS A SOMEBODY
WHO WAS SITTING IN THE LEFT
FIELD BLEACHERS -- IN OCTOBER OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
AND THANK YOU FOR IN STORE.
FOR SIR TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GREAT.
HI GREAT I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING.
I GEAR CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CONTACT [inaudible]
BRO.
BRO NOT VOTING COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER AYE DALY AYE DALY AYE
GALLAGHER.
AND WE'RE GARCIA GIPSON.
GIPSON I JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
LACKEY.
LOW HI LOW I MATHIS [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
WHEN DOES NOT VOTING QUIRK SILVA?
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
ROBERT RIVAS [inaudible]
BLANCA RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS AYE.
JONES SAWYER.
THERE [inaudible]
I JOHN SORRY I THE BILL NEEDS
ONE VOTE -- WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AT THANK YOU WITH
THE SERVICE.
RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
OKAY MEMBERS AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE. TO ITEM FIVE
SEEING ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
LOW MULLIN IN THE AUDIENCE.
AND WE'RE STILL PAGING MISTER
ROB BONTA MISTER ROB BONTA
PLEASE REPORT TO ROOM
[inaudible]
FORTY TWO OH TWO CALLER
.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THANK YOU -- AND WE DO HAVE AYE
TWO WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT OF
AB AT A FOUR EIGHT SIX AT TO
SPEAKING FOR THE BILL SO WE CAN
MAKE IT BRIEF WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND.
HI I'M JUDY MANN CRUISE SO
SPONSORED THE BILL SOCIAL
COMPASSION LEGISLATION -- WE'VE
HAD THIS IN OUR JURISDICTION IN
LAGUNA BEACH WE'VE HAD OUR OVER
FAIR SHARE OF DISASTERS I AM A
PERMIT HOLDER BECAUSE I HAVE
OVER THE LIMIT OF ANIMALS.
AND I WAS MADE TO HAVE AN
EVACUATION PLAN AND IT'S A
WONDERFUL THING AND I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR GRAY AND HIS
STAFF FOR MAY BE MAKING THE BILL.
EVEN BETTER IN THE CLARIFICATION
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI THERE -- MY NAME'S DOCTOR HAD
THE RALLY I'M THE SUPERVISING
VETERINARIAN AT THE PETER
FOUNDATION -- I IT WAS OF A
RESIDENT OF SANTA BARBARA WHEN
THE THOMAS FIRE BROKE OUT
VENTURA AND PERSONALLY HAVE SEEN
FIRST HAND FOR WHILE WORKING
DURING THAT DISASTER WITH THE
VICTIMS -- OF THAT THE
UNFORTUNATE ANIMALS OF
UNPREPARED AND IT OF GUARDIANS
WERE CAUGHT OFF GUARD PANICKED
AND UNPREPARED AND THIS IS A
LIFE SAVING BILL AND I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT IT PLEASE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SEEING NONE. TO THE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND.
YEAH JUST TO CONFIRM YOUR TIED
THAT SEE COMMITTEE IN MINUTES
YES WONDERFUL SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
GREAT HI THREE I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AYE GEAR CURRY.
BERMAN [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
COOL.
COOLEY.
HI COOLEY AYE COOPER.
UBER HI DALY.
DALY AYE A GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIVE SEND HI GIPSON AYE JONES
SAWYER WAS BONTA AYE.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY
[inaudible]
LOW.
LOW I AM NOT THIS [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
WHEN DOES NOT VOTING QUIRK SILVA?
QUIRK SILVA AYE ROBERT RIVAS.
BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS
[inaudible]
SALAS EYEING.
THAT BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OKAY AT THIS TIME MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO ASK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ TO PLEASE APPROACH --
TO PRESENT HIS BILL MEMBERS THIS
IS ITEM EIGHT A. B. NINE ONE ONE
RODRIGUEZ.
WELCOME SIR YOU HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
MR CHARMERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE ELEVEN I WANT
TO READ BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
CALIFORNIA CARLY'S HOME TO EIGHT
MILLION PERSONS WHO ARE EITHER
ORDER ADULTS OR PERSONS WITH
MOBILITY.
CENTURY INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT
AND OR MENTAL HEALTH
DISABILITIES.
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE CONSIDERED
AT RISK AND HAVE UNIQUE NEEDS
AND BERKELEY HIT REQUIRE SPECIAL
RICK ACCOMMODATIONS ESPECIALLY
DURING CASE OF EMERGENCY OR THEY
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO CLEARLY
COMMUNICATE WITH FOR FOR
SPONSORS.
AB NINETY LEVEL DIRECT CAL --
YES DEVELOP A PLAN AND TIMELINE
FOR THE TESTING IMPLEMENTATION
AND OPERATION OF A STATEWIDE
SYSTEM.
THAT WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIANS TO
VOLUNTARY SUBMIT LIMITED
PERSONAL HEALTH INFORMATION. TO
BE MADE AVAILABLE FOR FOR FOR
SPONSORS.
ALSO WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS SEPARATE FROM THE
STATE'S PLANT UPGRADES TO THE
NEXT GEN NINE ONE TECHNOLOGY.
IT WILL IN NO WAY HINDER THOSE
EFFORTS WITH ME TODAY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY.
FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE OF HOME
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS IS
CRISTINA HAMILTON FROM U. D. W..
THANK YOU SO MANY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL THANK YOU
CHAIR MEN GRAY THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE -- AB NINE ELEVEN
IS A LABOR OF LOVE FOR YOU W.
I'M SPECIFICALLY FOR OUR VICE
PRESIDENT ASHES YOU NEED A SHE
WAS PLANNING -- TO BE HERE TODAY
TO TESTIFY SHE BROUGHT HER SON
MANNY -- THE THE BILL IS NAMED
THE MANY ALERT ACT --
UNFORTUNATELY MANY HAS VERY
SEVERE AUTISM AND WAS NOT ABLE
TO COME INTO THE BUILDING IT WAS
TOO MUCH -- STIMULUS AND HE HAD
A A REALLY NEGATIVE REACTION SO
SHE'S VERY SAD THAT SHE CAN'T BE
HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE BILL SO
I'M I'M HERE IN HER PLACE -- THE
GOAL FOR EIGHTY NINE ELEVEN IS.
TO GIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT OF FIRST
RESPONDERS IN ADVANCE OF
EMERGENCIES INFORMATION THAT
THEY CAN USE TO RESPOND
APPROPRIATELY AND IN FACT WOULD
HAPPEN WITHOUT SHOULDN'T HER SON
TODAY RIGHT OUTSIDE THE BUILDING.
IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF WHY THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS SO IMPORTANT --
DUE TO HIS -- DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES -- HER SON IS
TWENTY YEARS OLD.
FROM THE OUTSIDE LOOKING IN YOU
WOULD NOT KNOW THAT HE HAS THESE --
IMPAIRMENTS BUT HIS RESPONSE IF
YOU DID NOT KNOW THIS WOULD BE
EXTREMELY DISTURBING AND FOR
SOMEONE COMING FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHO DOES NOT KNOW
THAT.
HE HAS THIS CONDITION WOULD NOT
KNOW HOW TO RESPOND WOULD
INTERPRET IT AS HIM ASSAULTING
HIS MOTHER -- IN SO HER CONCERN
IS THAT HE IS OF A A YOUNG MAN
WHO IS PRONE TO WANDER FROM HOME
HE DOES RUN AWAY FROM HOME.
SHE LIVES IN FEAR OF HIS BEING
FOUND BY LAW ENFORCEMENT HE WILL
NOT RESPOND TO COMMANDS BECAUSE
HE DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO AND THEY
WILL NOT KNOW HOW TO INTERPRET
THAT.
AND AND WILL RESPOND NEGATIVELY
SO WHAT THE BILL IS TRYING TO DO
IN ADVANCE OF A NINE ONE ONE IS
CREATED TECHNOLOGY WHICH ALREADY
EXISTS AND IN FACT OTHER STATES
HAVE ADOPTED IT.
WE'RE A FAMILY CAN PRO ACTIVELY
CHOOSE TO A AN OPEN INDIVIDUAL
CAN DO THIS ON THEIR OWN ALSO IT
DOESN'T SAY WHO COUNTER WHO
CAN'T WHOEVER WANTS.
TO CAN GIVE THEIR INFORMATION TO
THE DISPATCHER SO THAT IT
BECOMES AVAILABLE SOON AS YOUR
PHONE.
CALLS 911- THAT INFORMATION IS
POPULATED FOR THE NINE ONE ONE
DISPATCHER AND THEY THEN WOULD
GIVE THAT INFORMATION TO WHOEVER
THE FIRST RESPONDER IS.
SO THAT THEY ARE AWARE AS THEY
GO INTO A SITUATION WITH WHAT
AND WHOM THEY'RE DEALING WITH
AND WHAT AN APPROPRIATE RESPONSE
SHOULD BE.
AND SO AGAIN SHE ASKED ME TO
READ THIS A STATEMENT.
SHE SAID JUST TELL THE COMMITTEE
I SAID THANK YOU FOR LETTING US
COME IN TODAY AND UNFORTUNATELY.
MANUEL WAS NOT WAS OVER
STIMULATED AND WAS NOT ABLE TO
MAKE IT HE IS GOOD NOW I'M
HOPING THAT THERE WILL BE ENOUGH
OPPORTUNITY IN THE FUTURE.
THAT THEY WILL GET TO MEET MANNY
AND THESE ARE THE VERY REASONS
WHY WE NEED AN ALERT SYSTEM LIKE
THIS SO THAT WHEN HE HAS CONTACT
WITH FIRST RESPONDERS THE
UNDERSTAND WHAT HE'S GOING
THROUGH IS A MELTDOWN -- IT WAS
ACTUALLY VERY TRAUMATIC ENOUGH
SETTING UP BEFORE THE HEARING
STARTED TODAY SO I I URGE
SUPPORT OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THIS BILL WE DID SUBSTANTIAL
AMENDMENTS. TO ADDRESS --
CONCERNS FROM -- YES WE KNOW
THIS TECHNOLOGY EXISTS WE KNOW
THE STATE IS ALREADY UPDATING
THE NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM SO IT
SEEMS VERY LOGICAL THAT WE WOULD
WANT THE STATE TO UPDATE THE
SYSTEM WITH THE MOST ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGY.
THAT WOULD HOPEFULLY GIVE FIRST
RESPONDERS TOOLS TO PREVENT
NEGATIVE ENCOUNTERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
JORDAN LINDSAY WITH THE ARK
CALIFORNIA AND UNITED TRIPLE
POLICY CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION --
AS WE HEARD WE WE THINK VERY
MUCH AS WOMEN RODRIGUEZ FOR
BRING THIS BILL FORD --
UNFORTUNATELY IN CALIFORNIA AS
WELL THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
WE'VE SEEN INCIDENTS WHERE
ACTIONS OR MISINTERPRETED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR FIRST RESPONDERS
AS POTENTIALLY THREATENING.
AND THAT HAS RESULTED IN
TRAGEDIES THAT IS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO AVOID -- ASSUMING
COOPER HELD A WONDERFUL
INFORMATIONAL HEARING LAST YEAR
ABOUT TO VARIOUS -- TECHNOLOGIES
IN VARIOUS APPROACHES THAT
LOCALITIES ARE ALREADY TAKING --
HOWEVER THIS WOULD MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE ABLE TO DO THIS
STATEWIDE -- AND AND WHILE IT
WILL FOR SURE AND IMPROVE THE
OUTCOMES FOR PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES -- FOR INSTANCE
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE FIRES HAVE
BEEN MENTIONED PERHAPS YOU COULD
SAY -- OR MY MOTHER MY
GRANDMOTHER IS ON THE SECOND
FLOOR SHE NEEDS HELP CAN DOWN
THE STAIRS AND WHICH TO RESPOND
WOULD INSTANTLY KNOW THAT THERE
IS A PERSON THE SECOND FLOOR WHO
MIGHT NEED HELP GETTING DOWN.
HOW TO THIS EMERGENCY -- SO IT
HAS BROAD IMPLICATIONS AND WE
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ERIC HARRIS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
KATRINA PICKLE I SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS COULD
USE ON WITH UT W. AND WE URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES ON THIS BILL.
THE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY EXPORT
ANY TESTIMONY TODAY IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS. FOR STARTERS
ALL THANK YOU ARE FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD -- AS SOMEONE
pFAMILY PERSONALLY -- KNOWN FOR
YEARS TO LIVE IN THE AREA THAT I
REPRESENT AND DIED KNOW THE
STRUGGLES AND THE WORRY.
THAT SHE HAS LEFT WITH -- THE
CERTAINLY IMPORTANT -- BILL FOR
FAMILIES LIKE THEIRS AND
APPRECIATE -- YOU TAKING ON A
DIFFICULT ISSUE THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
PUT THE BILL AND THE BEST SHAPE
POSSIBLE TO MOVE FORWARD.
WITH RESPECT AS FIVE UP THINKING.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
GREAT.
HI GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
BRO.
BRO I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
IN THIS.
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW AYE MATHIS.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE AYE QUIRK
SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I ROBERT RIVAS.
BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO HIGH [inaudible]
SALAS.
SALAS NIGHT OF ROBERT REED AS
NICE.
SALAS.
YOU DO BOTH.
THE BILL HAS -- THIRTEEN WELL TO
TOUT ITS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OKAY AT THIS TIME MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM ELEVEN ON
YOUR AGENDA WE'RE GONNA ASPECTS
CUTTING HIM TO PLEASE --
APPROACH DIES SUPPORT.
PRESENT YOUR BILL WE'VE GOT A
SUPPORT SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION
ON THIS BILL WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND AS YOU APPROACH.
AND PLEASE PRESENT YOUR BILL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU MEMBERS I I WILL BE BRIEF IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME GOOD
AFTERNOON AS YOU ALL KNOW.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO A ROBUST
WIND AND DISTILLERY AND BREWERY
INDUSTRY IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE
THAT PLEASE COME TO MY DISTRICT
THAT'S THE THIRTY FIFTH AND
SAMPLE SOME OF OUR WARES -- THIS
BILL WOULD SUPPORT THAT INDUSTRY
BY ALLOWING QUALIFIED COLLEGE
STUDENTS TO TASTE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES.
BUT ONLY WHERE THE ACADEMIC
INSTITUTION HAS AN ESTABLISHED
ASSOCIATES ARE BACHELOR'S DEGREE
DEGREE PROGRAM IN HOTEL
MANAGEMENT OF THE OR THE
CULINARY ARTS.
WITH ME TODAY IS A PROFESSOR FOR
MY DISTRICT TO QUESTION SANTA
BARBARA CITY COLLEGE HE'S TO MY
LEFT.
AND THAT IS PROFESSOR MICHAEL
VON HECKLER HE LIKES A FEW WORDS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
BUT MY NAME IS MICHAEL VON
HECKLER AND I'M AN ADJUNCT
PROFESSOR OF WINE AT BOTH THE
CITY COLLEGE IN SANTA BARBARA
AND ALAN HANCOCK IN.
IN UP SANTA MARIA WE ALREADY
HAVE AN EXISTING LAW HERE OTHER
ALLOWS -- STUDENTS BETWEEN
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY ONE TO TASTE.
IN SCHOOLS WHERE WE HAVE AN
ANALOGY AND VITICULTURE PROGRAM.
BUT I BELIEVE THERE WAS A AN
OVERSIGHT IN NOT LISTING HOTEL
MANAGEMENT AND CULINARY ARTS.
AND AT CITY COLLEGE OUR
ADMINISTRATION IN LOOKING AT
THAT LOSS SAID WE DON'T HAVE AN
ELEGY VITICULTURE HERE SO.
YOU CAN'T TASTE IN CLASS SO
UNFORTUNATELY EVERY YEAR I GET
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE STUDENTS WHO
ARE IN THE CULINARY PROGRAM AND
IF THERE'S ONE STUDENT THE CLASS
WAS NINETEEN OR TWENTY WE HAVE
TO FOREGO TASTING.
ONE SO IT'S A BIG PART OF THE
CULINARY INDUSTRY FOR THE
STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO MATCH THE
ONE IN THE FOODS.
AND WHAT WE DO IS ENSURE THAT
THE STUDENTS ARE UNDER TWENTY
ONE UNDER MY SUPERVISION THEY
HAVE THEY ACTUALLY HAVE TO SPIT.
WHICH IS WHAT WE DO NORMALLY IN
THE WINE TASTING INDUSTRY.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
MAJORA'S SOME OUT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION -- THIS AFTERNOON.
SEEING NONE WILL GO AHEAD AND
BRING IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS I
SEE MISTER GALLAGHER -- MISTER
MINISTER MORE IN ABOUT THE
SLIPPERY SLOPE -- THAT COULD BE
ESTABLISHED BY THIS LEGISLATION
I MEAN WHAT'S NEXT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE POLITICAL SCIENCE MAJORS
COME IN HERE AND SAID THEY TOO
SHOULD BE ABLE TO TASTE UNDER
ASIAN MIX OF MAYBE THE AUTHOR
WOULD.
YOU KNOW BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
THAT CONCERN I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT.
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER GIVEN THAT YOU
REPRESENT CHICO STATE.
YOU SHOULD BE THE LAST PERSON TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HEY WE FULLER LARA IN CHICO
VENTURE [inaudible]
THIS COOLEY.
HI I WANT TO POINT OUT TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM EAST NICHOLAS.
THAT IS MUCH OF SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY HAS THE SEVEN MOUNTAINS
THE SEVEN SISTERS WOULD BE THE
SLIPPERY SLOPES.
AND AS A LOWER EXPECT A HIGHER
DEGREE OF PRECISION FROM YOU.
I'VE GOT SOME INTERESTING ISSUES
RAISED MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
LUCKILY -- BOTH MISTER BERMAN
MISTER REVISTA VOLUNTEERED TO
ORGANIZE THE TRIP DOWN TO YOUR
DISTRICT TO SAMPLE THE WARES AND
EXPLORE THE VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS
OF THE VARIOUS COLLEGES SINCE A
GRADUATE OF UCSB I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH ALL THIS TALK.
SURELY LOOK FOR TO COVER DOWN
THERE ISN'T THANKS FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD I APPRECIATE
YOU WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE.
TO IMPROVE THE BILL.
ALWAYS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE VOTE
LOOK WE HAVE OR TO THE FIELD
TRIP.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND WE
HAVE CLOSED SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
GREAT HI GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AYE YOUR CURRY.
BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BONTA.
BRO.
BRO I TOTALLY BLIND COOLEY AYE
COOPER.
DALY AYE DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I AND ORDER GARCIA
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER.
LIKE IF YOU TELL ME HOW TO
BECOME A PROFESSOR OF WINE.
THANK YOU.
YEAH.
LACKEY HI LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW AYE MATHIS.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE QUIRK
SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS
[inaudible]
BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU SIR.
OKAY AT THIS TIME MEMBERS LIST.
TOO LITTLE HOUSEKEEPING WHILE WE
ASK MISS IRWIN TO APPROACH.
THE DYESS WE'VE GOING TO RETURN
TO ITEM FIFTEEN THIS IS AB
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE FLORA -- WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
KEEPASS THOUSAND EIGHT TO PASS
AS AMENDED.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GREAT.
HI GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AYE GEAR CURRY.
BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
BRO.
BRO I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I AT ORDER GARCIA
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW I AM NOT THIS.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE AYE QUIRK
SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS.
THAT BILLS OUT WE'RE GONNA
RETURN MEMBERS NOT ITEM SEVEN AB
EIGHT FORTY THIS IS
A SON WERE DOLLARS BILL. TO PASS
AS AMENDED SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
GREAT HI GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AYE YOUR CURRY
[inaudible]
BERMAN.
THIS IS ITEM SEVEN AB EIGHT
FORTY DOLLARS.
BERMAN I BONTA.
BRO.
BRO I A COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER [inaudible]
DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER BY JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW AYE MATHIS.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE QUIRK
SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I AM ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS.
THAT BILLS OUT WE'RE GOING TO
RETURNED ITEM TO OPEN THE ROLE
IN AB TWO NINETY ONE OF PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA [inaudible]
GOD GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I LACKEY SO.
LACKEY NO MATHIS [inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS [inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS HI.
THAT BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE MISTER
[inaudible]
ONE IS PROCEEDS.
WITH YOUR PRESENTATION AS SOON
AS WE GET THAT DOOR SHUT.
MAY I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO
AB TWELVE FORTY TWO TWO THIS
AFTERNOON -- IT PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY OUT OF PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION YESTERDAY I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AND CONCEPT THAT ARE
DROPPED DESCRIBED ON THE
COMMITTEE AND IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS ON PAGE.
THREE WHEN I INTRODUCED THE BILL
EARLIER THIS YEAR IT WAS
INTENDED TO RAISE THE IMPORTANCE
OF CYBERSECURITY AFTER
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE I'M COMFORTABLE WITH THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT STRIKING OUT
THE NEW OFFICES -- PROVISIONS
HOWEVER ANOTHER COMPONENT OF AB
TWELVE FORTY TWO ARE THE
PROVISIONS RELATING TO CYBER
SECURITY OF THE STATE AGENCY
WOULD AGENCIES WHO DO NOT
DIRECTLY REPORT TO THE GOVERNOR.
THE LACK OF CYBER SECURITY
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR CERTAIN
INDEPENDENT AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AGENCIES HAS BEEN OF CONCERN TO
ME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OBERNOLTE AND I WERE
JOINT AUTHORS OF THE BILL LAST
YEAR THAT SOUGHT SIMILAR
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND UNIFORMITY IN THE CYBER
SECURITY COMPLIANCE.
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICES HOLD SOME
OF THE MOST CRITICAL DATA AND
FUNCTIONS FOR THE STATE AND
HAVING NO LEGISLATIVE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR HOUSE SECURE
THEIR NETWORKS ARE IS AN
ACCEPTABLE.
WE MUST BE ABLE TO VERIFY THAT
THEY ARE UNDERGOING INDEPENDENT
SECURITY ASSESSMENTS SECURITY
AUDITS AND ARE WORKING TO
REMEDIATE KNOWN VULNERABILITIES.
AS THIS BILL IS NARROWED IN THIS
COMMITTEE I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE INDEPENDENT AND
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICES AS WELL
AS MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
FIND APPROPRIATE WAY TO ENSURE.
CYBERSECURITY ACROSS THE STATE
WIDE ENTERPRISE.
THE CONSTITUTIONAL AS HAVE
RAISED CONCERNS INVOLVING A
PROCUREMENT AND CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST REGARDING WHO WILL
ASSESS THEIR SYSTEMS.
I AM CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN FIND
A SOLUTION THROUGH ALTERNATIVE
REPORTING MECHANISMS THAT CAN
REACH OUR SHARED GOAL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND HIGH
STANDARDS OF SECURITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
WILSHIRE SECOND.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING THAT IN THE TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION.
GIVE ME MARK ON BEHALF OF
SECRETARY STATE ALEX PADILLA --
WE JUST WANTED TO ECHO SORT OF
THE SENTIMENT THAT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NOTED THAT WE ABSOLUTELY
BELIEVE IN TRANSPARENCY IN
ACCOUNTING FOR ALL ENTITIES BUT
AT THIS TIME.
AND INTENTIONALLY AND IS
IMPLICATED.
THE FLEXIBILITY WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS ANY RISKS FOR
CYBERSECURITY AND ALSO -- FOR
THE COMP SELECTIVE INTEREST IN
OUR DISCUSSIONS THIS IS NOT AN
INTENT AND SO WE WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THESE PROVISIONS AND
THANK STAFF INVOLVED WITH ALL
THESE DISCUSSIONS.
IN ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
RUNNING COULD GEORGE ON BEHALF
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THE
CERAS OFFICE -- WE AS A SUPPORT
AT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GOALS OF
STANDARDIZATION ACROSS THE
AGENCIES AND FOR THEIR
COLLABORATION AND WERE SPECIALLY
I'M HAPPY TO HEAR -- HER
COMMENTS REGARDING -- HEARING
OUR OWN CONCERNS AND WILLING TO
WORK FURTHER ON THE AMENDMENTS
AND AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
WITH RESPECT. TO CONFLICT OF
INTEREST CAN AND RISK OF
EXPOSURE OF DATA FROM MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS BUT WE DO FEEL
I'M HOPEFUL THAT THE OUR OFFICES
CAN WORK TOGETHER. TO REACH A
COMPROMISE THAT WOULD -- SUPPORT
THE INTENT OF THE BILL AND AT
THE SAME TIME ALLOWING OUR
CONCERNS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME.
THE FOOD COMMON CERTAINLY
WELCOME TO HOST MISTER SERRA
OVER HERE A TIME -- TO ENGAGE IN
A DISCUSSION WITH THE SERVER.
ANY ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS MISTER GIPSON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER I
WANT TO THANK -- THE OFFER FROM
THOUSAND OAKS FOR ONE FOR
LEADERSHIP IN THE SPACE -- WE
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE -- ALSO
EDUCATE THE CAUCUS AS A WHOLE --
REGARDING CYBERSECURITY OF OUR
OWN PERSONAL -- COMMUNICATION
DEVICES AND INTERNET AND AND AND
I PASSING THINGS ALIKE SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THAT YOU MOVING IT
TO THE LEVEL OF MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE SECURE AND STATE IS ONE OF
OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICERS.
I THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE OF ALL THE CREATURES
WE'VE HAD -- THAT'S BEEN IN THE
NEWSPAPER HERE OF LATE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE -- SECURITY AMONG THOSE
SENSITIVE ITEMS THAT WE
POSSESSING COMMUNICATE WITH SO
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
LEADERSHIP AND WOULD LOVE FOR
YOU TO OUGHT TO ADD ME AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THE BILL.
SO I CAN BE PART OF THAT LIST
THAT YOU JUST READ OFF.
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY ADDITIONAL OUR COMMENTS
MUST LOVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER I
JUST WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
THAT THIS SUMMER GIPSON TOOK OUT
OF MY MOUTH TO AND ASK THAT YOU
WOULD ADD TO BE AS A CO AUTHOR
AS WELL ALL.
FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT ON THIS I
KNOW THAT YOU ALSO SERVICE CHAIR
OF THE ASSEMBLY SECURITY
COMMITTEE AND THE NATIONAL
CONFERENCE OF STATE LEGISLATURES
SO.
WE WILL LEAD BY EXAMPLE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
ANY ADDITIONAL.
MISS MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M
MISS IRWIN CAN YOU.
WE HAVE FOUR DIFFERENT.
OFFICES IN CHARGER CYBER
SECURITY IN THE STATE RIGHT NOW
RIGHT.
SO HAVE ANY OF THEM WE'VE GOT.
WHILE.
OKAY WE'VE GOT.
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT HIGHWAY
PATROL -- HAS HAVE ANY OF THEM
THE REQUESTED THIS BILL OR HAS
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE REQUESTED
THIS BILL THEY ARE AS IS SO --
WE'VE ALREADY PASSED BILLS AND
ABOUT FOUR YEARS AGO THAT
REQUIRED ASSESSMENTS AND AUDITS
OF ALL OUR STATE DEPARTMENTS
THOSE ARE UNDER THEY THEY'RE
UNDER DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
AND THEY REPORT TO DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY SO.
THIS IS CONSISTENCY WITH THE
CONSTITUTE AT MAKING SURE THAT
THE THE THE SAME ACCOUNTABILITY
IS PUT UPON THE CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICES SO THEY ARE ALREADY
DOING THE AUDITS THE ASSESSMENTS --
OF PATCHING VULNERABILITIES AND
AS THE GRADING THE MATURITY OF
ALL THE DIFFERENT -- STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND SEEING WHERE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES HAVE TO BE
PLACED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE SECURE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY THE DIVISIONAL Là COMMENTS
QUESTIONS CONCERNS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND.
THE AUTHOR HAS ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED MANY
AMENDMENTS -- SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
RIGHT.
HI GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
BONTA AYE BRO.
BRO I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
DALY OUR DAILY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDOGARCIA
GIPSON.
GIPSON I JONES SAWYER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE AYE QUIRK
SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I BLANCA RUBIO.
ON TO RUBIO AYE SALAS
[inaudible]
SALAS I THAT BILLS UP THANK YOU
THE SERVER THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY AT THIS TIME WE HAVE TO
AUTHORS LAUGHED AND TWO ITEMS
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE MISTER KING
FOLLOWED THE BRIEFLY --
AFTERWARDS BY MR CHIU ITEM.
THIRTEEN MISTER CHENEY EVER
SUPPORT SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
VERY QUICKLY I JUST WANT TO I
THANK THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE BILL -- TO
DISTRICT BILL IT CHANGES THE
BILL THAT WE PASSED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN A. B. FORTY FIVE A. B.
FORCIBLE WANT TO GIVE A LITTLE
MORE.
LATITUDE IN LIQUOR LICENSES
WITHIN SAN FRANCISCO
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
HEY THIS WAS TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS.
IT WOULD WOULD ORGANIZE A TRIP
TO MISTER KINGS DISTRICT.
PERHAPS THE RAPID GROWTH TOWARD
ALL THE LIQUOR LICENSE
FACILITIES AND WE ARE.
OKAY SQUARE VERSUS SECOND
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GREAT HI GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BONTA AYE BONTA AYE
BRO.
BRO I COOLEY.
THE AYE COOPER.
DALY AYE DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE A QUIRK
SILVA.
I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS
[inaudible]
SALAS I THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU
MYSTIC THANK YOU.
WHICH CHIU PLEASE -- APPROACH
MEMBERS IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A
SECOND OPPORTUNITY FOR SITE
VISITOR FOLLOW SAN FRANCISCAN.
WELL.
MYSTERY OF SOME.
MOTION AND A SECOND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD LOVE TO
INVITE ALL OF YOU TO COME AT ANY
TIME.
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
UNIQUE SAINT JOSEPH'S CHURCH IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
THIS FIRST CONSTRUCTED IN
NINETEEN THIRTEEN THE CHURCH WAS
DESIGNATED A NATIONAL HISTORIC
LANDMARK UNFORTUNATELY WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY DAMAGE IN THE
EIGHTY NINE LOMA PRIETA
EARTHQUAKE.
RE OPENED ITS DOORS LAST YEAR AS
THE HOME OF THE ST JOSEPH ARTS
SOCIETY A VERY NEW CULTURAL
INSTITUTION AND NONPROFIT --
DEDICATED TO THE ARTS DESIGN
FOOD FASHION LITERATURE
PERFORMANCE.
IT'S FOUNDATION OPENS THE CHURCH
TO THE PUBLIC AND IS AVAILABLE
TO LOCAL ARTISTS AND COMMUNITY
GROUPS UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS
NOT AN A. B. C. LICENSE THAT
WOULD PERMIT THE CHURCH TO HOLD
A LICENSE IN THE TYPES OF EVENTS
THE REVISION.
BECAUSE OF THIS ANY EVENT OF THE
CHURCH WHERE ALCOHOL IS SERVED
REQUIRES A PARTNERSHIP WITH
ANOTHER A. B. C. LICENSEE.
THE PROCESSING TIME TO PUT TO
COMPLETE THESE PARTNERSHIPS --
ARDUOUS AND COMPLEX AND THAT IS
WHY WE'RE HERE -- IN WITH THAT
LIKE TO TURN OVER TO OUR WITNESS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON AT CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S ALEXIS POLICY POLICY LAW
GROUP I WAS THE LAND USE
ATTORNEY THAT HELP WITH THE
REDEVELOPMENT OF SAINT JOSEPH'S
CHURCH AS WELL AS REPRESENTING.
SAINT JOSEPH'S CHURCH ARTS
SOCIETY AND FOUNDATION I'M GOING
TO THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
FOR INTRODUCING THIS LEGISLATION --
WHICH WILL ALLOW ST JOSEPH'S
ARTS SOCIETY AND FOUNDATION TO
OPERATE WITHIN SAINT JOSEPH'S
CHURCH PROVIDING ACCESS TO
CULTURAL ARTISTIC EVENTS AND
ASSETS THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
SAINT JOSEPH'S CHURCH AS A
NATIONAL LANDMARK IN A SAN
FRANCISCO HISTORIC LANDMARK IT'S
EIGHT BACON AND ON USE FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHU NOTED AFTER THE NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE LOMA PRIETA
EARTHQUAKE.
IT'S NOW RESTORED COMMUNITY AND
CULTURAL ASSETS THAT'S PROPOSED
FOR PUBLIC AND COMMUNITY USE IN
SUPPORT OF THE ARTS.
THE LICENSE PROPOSE WOULD ALLOW
ST JOSEPH'S ART FOUNDATION TO
OPERATE WITHIN THE SAINT
JOSEPH'S CHURCH AND ALLOW THE
SALE OF ALCOHOL DURING EVENTS
THAT ARE USED TO SUPPORT THE
MISSION AND THE FOUNDATION.
AS WELL AS VARIOUS NONPROFITS
AND COMMUNITY GROUPS SPONSORING
EVENTS AT THIS CHURCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR EVERY
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY -- IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE TO EVERY TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE ON THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION TO SECOND.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GREAT AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AYE GEAR CURRY
BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
BONTA AYE BRO.
BRO I A COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
DALY AYE DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY
[inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
NOT THIS.
MELENDEZ BLENDS AYE QUIRK SILVA.
SO THAT I ROBERT RIVAS.
I BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS
[inaudible]
SALAS.
THAT BILLS OUT WAS SHOOT THANK
YOU COME NEXT OKAY MEMBERS I'D
LIKE -- TO EXTEND THE THANK YOU
TO MERCED COUNTY SUPERVISOR
SCOTT SO THEY'RE FOR ATTENDING
TODAY'S HEARING.
AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE -- TO
LEAVE THE DESK OPEN UP HERE FOR
ADD ONS FOR THE NEXT FIVE
MINUTES -- FOR MEMBERS ALL THE
BILLS ARE OUT -- NOTHING ON CALL --
BUT PLEASE ADD ON IF YOU MISSED
A VOTE.
DOUBLE FOR EVERYTHING.
DID YOU GO FOR A BEACON.
I DON'T KNOW [inaudible]
YEAH
.
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON GOVERNOR
RIDGE ASIAN IS ADJOURNED